do you have a little bit of FOMO not
being a part of that reboot I mean of
course I would love to make a cameo I
can't because we're very Cavallari
hey did ask Cristen if she has FOMO
about not being part of the hills reboot
and what it would take to maybe get you
guys to cameo
I'm very Cavaliere yeah I don't know if
it's allowed but I would love to do that
yeah because I love that show it's my
favorite show I watch it obviously just
for Christine but we would love to do a
very Cavallari yeah what color is the
best reality television star to ever go
on air I told her the same thing
but I also feel like you are one of the
best of all time is there a little bit
of a Jimmy ask you for pro tips Jay
Keller was born star is this your first
time meeting him we've never met Jay he
never comes out to LA even she said like
how did I get him out here Heidi and
Spencer Pratt supporting Kristin
Cavallari at her little James pop up
last month let's talk very quickly about
the hills
how has shooting filming been going I'm
not sure what we're allowed to stay or
not we always get in trouble yeah do you
feel like you guys are really missing
her yeah she did say that she heard that
your sister miss Stephanie Pratt is the
villain and to ask you about this
what can you reveal her tell us I could
never imagine a sister being a villain
she's just been on reality TV in England
and there they like the baddies they
call them and she's just been like wound
up so I think she's just in character
it makes me how's it been having Mischa
involved definitely different for sure I
don't really I'm not
I don't film a lot with her oh you don't
know so I don't
other people are right who are you guys
spending the majority of your time on
screen time with very good just like any
of you guys the real stars of the hills
this season right well I can teach
others - Lee Waller and Jason yeah I'm
with Frankie and his wife Jen so I feel
like for us there's probably people yeah
we're the closest do we will see
everything is in process so far there's
been a lotta drama and I feel like it's
just ramping up yeah are you guys intact
with all the friendships with everyone I
think a lot of people are like fake
friend fake right a lot of people are
acquaintances or like you know we were a
group of people that hung out a long
time anyway I feel like I'm gonna get
the payers spilling on the hills reboots
and their little one
gunner loving the camera he's kind of a
ham for the camera I'm realizing are we
gonna see him a lot on the hills reboot
oh definitely the most of any child on
the hills
really Gunnar's the child stars it's so
fun to see how hands-on you guys
especially are with him does he take
after mom or dad more do we think
I don't know and those meltdowns come in
and I'm not sure it's my mom sure sure I
know that Spencer here's a big Taylor
Swift fan is gunner a big Taylor Swift
fan yet probably the biggest he loves
every time her songs come on he starts
dancing yeah they have their morning
routine with her expresso and hot cocoa
- Taylor Swift so he definitely loves
her what's it gonna take to get Taylor
on the hills reboot a little cameo have
you talked to - come on auntie K you
know I've already emailed 3 1 million
times about it
I would say maybe a larger budget yeah
that's probably have lots of prayers
wins honor does your family feel
complete right now no no our kids yeah I
want I think I want two more do you are
[Music]
the biggest star of very Cavallari mr.
Jay Cutler just told us the three is
actually easier than two so because you
can kind of hang out I don't know the
logic but he did that so now it's three
for sure